did you like total war war hammer were
you just a little bit disappointed that
it wasn't called total war hammer me too
but if you wanted a sequel to the
crossover strategy game then you're in
luck I'm Matt in this game spot news
update is full of real-time warfare
developer Creative Assembly revealed
total war war hammer to with a CG
trailer but it also announced several
details about the gameplay or hammer too
will feature for new playable races
including High Elves Dark Elves Lizard
Men and a yet-to-be-announced fourth one
Creative Assembly also claims that it
features a new style of narrative
campaign in which each of the four races
compete to either save or destroy the
great vortex before anyone else can
we'll keep you updated as more
information is revealed so make sure to
LIKE and subscribe to be the first to
know about all of the total war news
total war war hammer to is slated to
release this year owners of the first
game get a free update shortly after
launch that provides Warhammer to with a
combined campaign map of the regions
from both games this will let you play
through campaigns with any playable race
you own but while you wait for that why
not check out the latest episode of the
lobby where we discuss starcraft
remastered and the state of the realtime
strategy genre
[Music]
you
[Music]